[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti Oggi vi parlerò di
quattro concetti legati al tema
dell'evoluzione la cui comprensione ha
migliorato la qualità della mia vita e
Spero quindi che possano essere utili
anche a voi vi anticipo che per ogni
concetto vi proporrò una mia riflessione
personale e vi farò anche alcune domande
tranquilli non dovrete parlare ma
semplicemente alzare la mano iniziamo
subito dal primo Concetto per evolvere
dobbiamo adattarci
Charles Darwin in seguito studia
approfonditi sull'evoluzione giunta
questa conclusione non è la più forte
della specie che sopravvive nella più
intelligente ma quella che si adatta
meglio al cambiamento quando lessi per
la prima volta questa frase mi soffermai
su una parola cambiamento
pensai a tutte quelle volte in cui avevo
sperato in un cambiamento pensai anche a
quei momenti in cui un cambiamento mi
aveva destabilizzata quasi Immobilizzata
e infine pensai i periodi sereni della
mia vita in cui avevo sperato che nulla
cambiasse che tutto restasse così per
sempre chi prima e che dopo però
sperimenta che questo non è possibile
infatti la vita cambia e spesso ciò
cambia anche noi dato che credo molto
nell'importanza della condivisione
Poiché penso che condividere aiuti a
sentirsi meno soli e soprattutto a non
drammatizzare i propri problemi o
pensieri Vi chiedo Ora gentilmente di
alzare la mano Senza vergogna se in
questo momento state vivendo una fase di
cambiamento
ora alzi la mano grazie Chi di voi spera
in un cambiamento
e infine alzi la mano Chi di voi
desidera che nulla cambi nella propria
vita
Grazie Ecco io grazie a Darwin ebbe la
possibilità di riflettere sul legame tra
l'adattamento e il cambiamento e se
prima ero convinta che adattarsi
significasse rinunciare accontentarsi
poi invece capii che adattarsi in un
significa per forza rinunciare ma
piuttosto Accettare la propria
condizione e nonostante i possibili
problemi derivati da un cambiamento
inaspettato non gradito essere in grado
di ricominciare da un nuovo punto di
partenza per poi così continuare ad
evolvere continuiamo anche noi e
possiamo al secondo concetto il sapere
ci permette di evolvere
vedete questa immagine quella colorata
in arancione sembra una mandorla ma non
lo è è una struttura che si trova
all'interno del nostro cervello e si
chiama migala dovete sapere che se i
nostri antenati sono sopravvissuti e
anche grazie all'amigdala la quale in
situazioni percepite come pericolo si
attivava innescando una innescandola
risposta di attacco fuga fondamentale ai
fini della sopravvivenza Cosa succede
quando l'amigdala si attiva gli effetti
possono essere vari ad esempio
sensazione d'ansia tachicardia
sudorazione intensa stato di agitazione
e questi sono solo alcuni li avete un
po' riconosciute Ma perché ve ne sto
parlando perché ritengo che vi sia utile
conoscere il ruolo il funzionamento
dell'amigdala perché potreste pensare
che l'amigdala si attivi solo in
situazioni in cui la nostra
sopravvivenza è messa in pericolo ma non
è così infatti l'amigdala si che in
tutte quelle situazioni legate alla
quotidianità da cui però non possiamo
fuggire e nemmeno attaccare per capire
meglio iniziamo con l'analizzare una
situazione in cui l'attivazione
dell'amigdala e a noi molto utile ad
esempio state camminando Siete solo in
un vicolo è buio a un tratto sentite il
rumore di passi in lontananza
avvicinarsi verso di voi la vostra MIG
dalla si attiva e voi siete pronti ad
attaccare o fuggire nel caso in cui si
tratti di un malintenzionato Anzi
Probabilmente Avete già iniziato a
correre onde evitare il possibile
problema
vediamo Ora invece è una situazione in
cui l'attivazione dell'amigdala non è a
noi molto utile ad esempio siete al
supermercato vi dirigete verso la cassa
per pagare c'è molta coda perché c'è
solo una cassa aperta Siete in ritardo a
un tratto una persona cerca di superarvi
la vostra MIG dalla si attiva e voi
attaccate verbalmente con la persona
iniziando così un litigio il giorno dopo
Ripensando alla situazione ammettete a
voi stessi che in effetti avreste potuto
rispondere e reagire in modo differente
ad esempio dicendo quella persona guardi
immagini che lei sia in ritardo però
vede lo sono anch'io Quindi non posso
permetterle di superarmi provi con
qualcun altro
situazioni come questa possono avvenire
quando siamo in macchina in posta Quando
un collega ci fa uno screzio quando
parcheggiando al centro commerciale
qualcuno ci accusa di avergli rubato il
posto non è sempre la nostra amigdala ad
attivarsi a volte subiamo le reazioni
altrui ma il comportamento degli altri
Non possiamo cambiarlo quello che invece
possiamo fare imparare a controllare e
migliorare le nostre direzioni
dovete Infatti sapere che acquisendo
consapevolezza potrete essere in grado
di disattivare l'amigdala e riportarla
ad uno stato di riposo per permettere al
vostro cervello di elaborare una
risposta immediatamente non il giorno
dopo più adatte più utile al fine di
risolvere quel determinato problema e
quindi fondamentale acquisire un certo
grado di consapevolezza e proprio di
questo parleremo nel terzo concetto
essere consapevoli ci consente di
evolvere
se in questo momento vi chiedessi di
venire sul palco per parlare un minuto
qualcuno di voi potrebbe essere
entusiasta qualcun altro invece potrebbe
iniziare a provare ansia ma come mai la
stessa azione può provocare sensazioni
opposte questo avviene perché il
cervello di ciascuno di noi oltre a
memorizzare l'azione Memorizza anche la
sensazione L'emozione che è stata
approvata nel compierla creando una
memoria emozionale
per rendervi consapevoli delle vostre
memorie emozionali ho pensato di
proporvi una lista di azioni mentre
leggete fate caso all'emozione alla
sensazione che ogni singola azione
rievoca in voi iniziamo guidare
parlare in pubblico
prendere l'aereo
chiedere un favore
sciare
parlare in inglese
vi lascio un attimo per rileggerle
E ora vi chiedo alzi la mano Chi di voi
ha collegato l'azione del parlare in
pubblico all'agitazione
chi invece ha collegato l'azione del
parlare in pubblico all'entusiasmo
E ora vi chiedo chi ha collegato
l'azione del chiedere un favore al
imbarazzo
Ma come si crea una memoria emozionale
vi faccio qualche esempio
pensate a un bambino un ragazzo a cui
piaceva molto ballare Ma che ha smesso
perché un giorno un suo parente gli fece
notare che il ballo era una cosa da
femmina non da maschi ovviamente il
parente Aveva torto Però quel ragazzo ha
smesso di ballare oppure pensate
all'insegnante che dice a un bambino
mentre Questo sta parlando di fronte a
tutta la classe che è imbranato
E così tutti i compagni iniziano a
deriderlo quel bambino ha già adulto
ogni volta che deve parlare di fronte ai
suoi colleghi provo una agitazione tale
che spesso dimentica Cosa vuole dire
invece adesso Voglio farvi notare
un'altra cosa pensate ora tutte quelle
azioni che inizialmente vi provocavano
agitazione ad esempio per guidare
parlare in inglese sciare Ma che poi con
la pratica e acquisendo con sicurezza vi
sono invece piaciute Ecco Dipende tutto
dall'esperienza che viviamo ed è
fondamentale rendersi conto che
l'esperienza non sono solo casuali
alcune possiamo crearle noi per essere
più chiara se ad oggi vi disturba il
fatto che quando dovete esporre un
vostro progetto durante una riunione di
lavoro a causa della agitazione non
riuscite ad esprimervi come vorreste e
così risultati impacciati non siete
obbligati ad abituarvi a quella
sensazione Anche se ormai sono anni che
la provate potete cambiare tutto ciò
come ad esempio prendendo in
considerazione di farvi affiancare da un
vocal coach di iscrivervi questo corso
di teatro e queste sono solo alcuni
esempi e sappiate che vale per ogni
azione possiamo sempre fare qualcosa per
migliorare
Ovvio non raggiungeremo già dalla prima
volta il risultato ma attraverso gli
sbagli i momenti di insicurezza possiamo
continuare a provare proprio di sbagli
parleremo Nel quarto e ultimo concetto
gli errori sono utili all'evoluzione
In quanti a quanti di voi è capitato di
farsi bloccare dalle proprie paure o
meglio dalla paura di sbagliare di non
essere all'altezza di non piacere e così
non provare nemmeno alzate pure la mano
se vi è capitato almeno una volta
anche a me capitava spesso anni fa
finché ho compreso che non aveva senso
limitarmi nell'agire per paura di
sbagliare Credo invece che sia
fondamentale rendersi conto che
sicuramente sbaglieremo Ma che sbagliare
non significa fallire
pensiamo a flaming il quale scoprì la
penicillina grazie alla sua capacità di
saper cogliere un'opportunità nonostante
essa fosse la conseguenza di un errore
oppure pensiamo a ridextings il quale in
seguito il fallimento della sua prima
attività decise di riprovare fondando
Netflix ora non voglio dire che ogni
errore ci porti a una grande innovazione
una grande attività imprenditoriale
perché così lo sappiamo bene nella
realtà non è
Credo invece che se sia delle persone
volenterose da ogni errore si possa
comunque imparare qualcosa di nuovo
perché gli errori sono dannosi solo se
da essi non impariamo nulla e ciò che ho
imparato io è che dipende solo da noi
trarre il meglio
dall'esperienza che la vita ci offre
dopo ogni cambiamento Saremo diversi Ma
possiamo sempre ricominciare da ogni
errore possiamo imparare qualcosa di
nuovo attraverso la consapevolezza
possiamo migliorare in ciò che ci limita
siamo fatti per evolvere ed evoluzione
per me significa cambiamento finalizzato
al miglioramento Grazie
[Applauso]